MICHEL DEGRAFF: So for me,
the best part, actually
one of the best
parts of the course,
was having students present
parts of the material.
And there was one
challenge that often--
there was a
temptation to just do
a summary of what you had read.
But the point was not
just to give a summary.
It was to be able to integrate
the readings with the larger--
I call it the germ of ideas.
And I use that term based
on previous readings
that we have done earlier in
previous years in this course.
But that's wasn't always easy.
Because there's a big difference
between doing a summary
and then taking the ideas
of readings and then
incorporating them into your
own reading of the course,
into personal issues, into
communal or critical issues.
And for me, I wanted them
to be able to do that too.
And the motive for that,
which was based on a reading
by Paulo Freire
and Donaldo Macedo
was as you read the word, you
also have to read the world.
And so, it's not enough
to just look at the text
as if it's a text.
You have to be able to
connect the text with issues
of actuality, which
could be personal,
which could be political,
which could be international.
And at the end, they did get to
do that in sometimes the most
beautiful, moving ways.
And often, after a while,
it got very personal.
It would bring up
personal issues
about their upbringing,
which they would connect
to the linguistic biography.
So for me, it was a very
rewarding part of the course,
to see them being able
to make those connections
between abstract,
complex analysis
and what they live on
a day-by-day basis.